con la lectura de los nombres de los 155
candidatos constituyentes estoy dando
inicio formalmente a esta ceremonia con
más de tres horas de retraso y en un
ambiente de muchísima tensión ha sido
una mañana de muchos dimes y diretes de
muchos va y viene todo comenzó
aproximadamente a las diez y media de la
mañana cuando un grupo de
aproximadamente 200 personas rompió la
barrera que se había conformado en torno
al ex congreso donde se está celebrando
esta inauguración y este grupo de
protestantes con pancartas con gritos
con consignas relacionadas con el
estallido social fue reprimido duramente
por la policía antes un grupo de
constituyentes protestó por la represión
que se lleva a cabo contra los
manifestantes y aclaró que no iba a
llevarse a cabo en la inauguración
mientras se seguirá reprimiendo fuera
del edificio a personas esto ha hecho
que se haya en los
constituyentes saliendo y entrando vía
del edificio y en estos momentos
sigue en marcha la ceremonia